تنتج معامل الطاقه الكهربائيه في لبنان
اربع ساعات يوميا فقط من حاجات البلاد
وياتي ذلك في اطار خطه لاعاده التيار
الكهربائي تدريجيا للمواطنين لكنه يحتاج
الى دعم البنك الدولي الذي اشترط رفع
تعريفه الكهرباء وهو ما التزمت به الحكومه
ارتفع
سعر 27 سانتا ويعد من الاعلى في المنطقه
فهذه التعريفه تزيد بنحو 20% عن تعريفات
الكهرباء في الاردن ومئه في المئه عن
السعر في تركيا ومئه وخمسين في المئه عن
قبرص وبذلك تكون الكلفه الشهريه لهذه
الساعات الاربع من الكهرباء نحو اربعين
دولارا لكل منزل لكن ذلك لا يكفي حاجه
السكان فالمواطنون يعتمدون ايضا على
المولدات الكهربائيه الخاصه يوميا تنقسم
فاتوره الكهرباء لكل منزل الى قسمين قسمين
يسدد للاشتراكات في المولدات الكهربائيه
الخاصه وقسم ثاني يسدد لشركات كهربائي
لبنان وبذلك تكون تكلفه الكهرباء نحو ضعف
راتب الموظف شهريا لكن رغم تنفيذ الحكومه
احد ابرز شروط البنك الدولي برفع تعريفه
الكهرباء فان خطه استعادتها في لبنان
امامها عقبات عده
اولها اعتماد مجموعه اصلاحات للحصول على
التمويل من البنك الدولي فالجهات المانحه
تعتبر ان قطاع الكهرباء اسهم في نحو 40%
من الديون التي تراكمت على لبنان نتيجه
دعم اسعار الكهرباء وعدم رفع نسبه جبايات
الفواتير
اما عدم اجراء الاصلاحات التي اشترطها
البنك الدولي فسيؤدي الى عدم حصول لبنان
على التمويل الضروري لاستجرار الطاقه من
الاردن والغاز من مصر لتوليد الكهرباء
ومضاعفه عدد ساعات التغذيه
واضافه الى العوامل الماليه وتقنيه تبرز
السياسه عائقا اضافيا في هذا المجال
فمرور الغاز المصري والكهرباء الاردنيه
عبر سوريا يحتاج الى استثناء امريكي من
عقوبات قيصر وهو ما تعده قوى محليه وعلى
راسها حزب الله اللبناني وسيله ضغط
لانتزاع تنازلات سياسيه ايهاب العقد
الجزيره بيروت